[Música]
no es ningún secreto en los países más
ricos cada vez son menos las personas
que quieren tener hijos la caída de la
natalidad es prácticamente un fenómeno
generalizado en todo el mundo
desarrollado parece Claro que va a
convertirse en uno de los mayores retos
en un futuro muy próximo hablamos de
países cada vez más envejecidos y con
menos niños de hecho la mayoría de los
países desarrollados ya están muy por
debajo de la tasa de reemplazo es decir
por debajo de los 2,1 hijos por mujer en
edad fértil que harían falta para que al
menos la población se mantuviera estable
sin contar Claro está la inmigración sin
embargo hay un caso concreto un país en
el que ya no es que la gente tenga de
media menos de dos hijos por mujer es
que ni siquiera llegan a uno hablamos
del país con menos natalidad de todo el
mundo y sí como ya os habréis imaginado
aunque solo sea por la miniatura y el
título de este vídeo Estoy hablando de
Corea del Sur fijaos concretamente
hablamos de de fecundidad de solo 0,78
hijos por mujer en 2022 un nivel tan
bajo que casi que podríamos decir que en
Corea tener niños ha convertido en toda
una anomalía y ojo porque en seúl esta
tasa todavía es peor agarrados a la
Silla hablamos de tan solo 0,59 hijos
por mujer casi una cuarta parte que la
tasa de reemplazo es decir que en este
caso no es que Corea del Sur esté
atravesando un invierno demográfico es
que prácticamente estamos ante la
crónica de una extinción anunciada
[Música]
a pesar de ser uno de los países más
ricos y avanzados del mundo Corea del
Sur se enfrenta un problema colosalco y
de solución No resulta nada fácil un
problema que podría provocar una
catástrofe demográfica en este país como
nunca antes se haya visto una catástrofe
demográfica y de no cambiar las cosas
quizás también una catástrofe económica
y es que aún contando con la fuerte
robotización de la industria de seguir
así las cosas es posible que en poco
tiempo no haya trabajadores suficientes
como para mantener en marcha su economía
sus fábricas sus comercios sus colegios
y los negocios de todo tipo
y no no estamos exagerando para nada
fijaos un momento En este gráfico os
dais cuenta de lo que esto significa lo
que estáis viendo es la proyección de la
población de Corea del Sur Durante las
próximas décadas como podéis ver a día
de hoy el país de la mañana tranquila ya
habría alcanzado su máximo histórico de
población a partir de ahora su población
no solo será mucho más anciana sino que
además comenzará a perder población y no
penséis que lo hará lentamente en los
próximos 40 años este país perderá más
de 12 millones de habitantes un 25% de
toda su población lo que en términos
demográficos es una auténtica salvajada
y eso no es todo para finales de siglo
de seguir la tendencia actual se espera
que la población surcoreana se reduzca a
menos de la mitad Es decir de casi 52
millones de habitantes hoy poco más de
20 no hay ningún otro país en todo el
mundo con unas previsiones tan malas
hablamos de un escenario en el que no
solo los surcoreanos pueden terminar
desapareciendo sino que además en el
proceso podría destruirse tanta riqueza
que los que vayan quedando se
enfrentarán a enormes dificultades
pensadlo bien si las previsiones se
cumplen muchos de los niños que están
naciendo hoy verán a su país con la
mitad de población cuando se jubilen con
todo lo que implica más gasto social
menos ahorro menos consumo etcétera
etcétera y ojo que no hablamos de una
hipótesis remota sino de un proceso que
ya se ha puesto en marcha tras años con
la tasa de natalidad absolutamente
hundida en el país ya hay muchos casos
de escuelas primarias hospitales y
servicios obstétricos y pediátricos que
están teniendo que echar el cierre
ahora bien puede que llegados a este
punto muchos os estaréis preguntando por
qué diablos está pasando esto en un país
donde supuestamente la economía va
viento en popa y a la gente no le falta
de nada Cuáles son exactamente los
motivos por los que los surcoreanos ya
no quieren tener hijos Qué está haciendo
el estado para revertir esta situación
tiene acaso alguna solución pues bien en
este vídeo os vamos a responder a todas
estas y más preguntas así que
atentos porque esta es la historia del
país que está corriendo hacia su propia
extinción
los cuatro no es
como os podéis imaginar un desastre como
este que os estamos contando no es algo
que ocurra porque sí hay motivos y no
son precisamente pocos ni fáciles de
explicar pero aquí en visualpolitik os
lo vamos a tratar de contar de la forma
más sintetizada posible Y es que veréis
lo más fácil sería culpar a los salarios
bajos la hiper competitividad
profesional que hay en Corea o aquí las
mujeres prefieren centrarse en sus
carreras antes que ponerlas en riesgo
para tener hijos pero no Aunque Estos
factores tienen parte de la culpa no nos
sirven para explicar por qué Corea es el
país con menos natalidad del mundo al
fin y al cabo todas estas cosas también
pasan en otros lugares Entonces qué día
antes hace que el problema en Corea del
Sur haya alcanzado tal magnitud
pues veréis ya os adelanto que algunas
cosas os van a chocar y mucho por un
lado tenemos que la sociedad surcoreana
es quizás una de las sociedades más
conservadoras y tradicionales de entre
todos los países desarrollados y vale Sí
ya sé lo que estaréis pensando pero a
ver Alberto sin esto de la natalidad la
sociedad es conservadoras suelen tener
ventaja No pues no no siempre uno de los
problemas que tienen en el país de la
mañana tranquila es su forma
extremadamente puritana o tradicional de
concebir la maternidad y los modelos de
familia de hecho virtualmente solo
existe una familia la que está compuesta
entre una mujer y un hombre y luego los
hijos claro todo lo que está fuera de
este marco se queda en la práctica fuera
del sistema y con ello la sociedad
surcoreana pierde un montón de
oportunidades para solucionar como
mínimo mitigar su problema de falta de
niños pero como sé que este motivo que
he dicho os estará chocando e incluso
alguno de vosotros os estará realizando
os vamos a dar datos y ejemplos
concretos fijaos
[Música]
en Corea solo el 2,9% de los bebés que
nacieron en el año 2021 lo hicieron
fuera de un matrimonio mientras que la
media de la ocd es atención del 40%.
esto es 16 veces más En otras palabras
casi un 40% de los niños que podrían
nacer en Corea del Sur Simplemente no lo
hacen es decir que la sociedad
surcoreana no concibe tener hijos y no
existe de por medio un matrimonio
tradicional estar casados es un
requisito ineludible para tener hijos y
no no es que religiosa o socialmente
sean muy diferentes o que tengan más
apetito por el matrimonio que ya os
adelanto que no es una cuestión sobre
todo cultural
en el caso de las madres solteras por
ejemplo muchas se enfrentan al juicio de
una sociedad en la que el honor y el que
dirán tienen todavía demasiado peso y
qué queréis que os diga en Corea del Sur
tener un hijo fuera del matrimonio está
muy mal visto y no hablemos ya de
familias del mismo sexo en general en
este país se consideran que todas estas
cosas son algo malo para los niños y Lo
siento Aunque el resto del mundo
desarrollado no parezca sumergido en el
Apocalipsis en este vídeo vamos a entrar
en esa cuestión aquí lo que nos importa
es el impacto que esto tiene en las
tasas de natalidad
[Aplausos]
El caso es que toda esta presión
cultural obliga a las mujeres a tomar
una decisión Buscar a toda Costa un
marido para poder tener hijos o desistir
de la maternidad y centrarse en ellas
mismas y en sus carreras profesionales Y
si eso es exactamente lo que muchas
mujeres están haciendo optar por esta
segunda opción luego os contaremos con
más detalles por qué pero el caso es que
al final cada vez menos mujeres están
dispuestas a tener descendencia lo que
lógicamente contribuye a que la tasa de
natalidad esté por los suelos pero es
para un momento porque no todos son tan
malas noticias afortunadamente la
sociedad también está cambiando y poco a
poco cada vez más gente acepta que la
maternidad se produzca fuera del
matrimonio tradicional por ejemplo en
los 10 años que transcurrieron entre
2012 y 2022 la aceptación de la
maternidad estando soltera ha crecido
más de 12 puntos de poco más del 22 a
casi el 35% de los encuestados Claro que
las instituciones públicas todavía
avanzan más lentas como siempre por
ejemplo en la definición que hace la ley
surcoreana de salud materno infantil
sobre el término subfertividad se hace
referencia explícita a una pareja casada
es decir no existe otra posibilidad para
recibir apoyo en tratamientos de
fertilidad de una forma u otra al
sistema excluye a las mujeres solteras
del acceso a los tratamientos de
fertilidad o fecundación in vitro
aún más la ley de seguridad y bioética
surcoreana dice que cualquiera que
busque realizar un tratamiento de
fecundación in vitro debe contar con el
consentimiento de su pareja o en otras
palabras que se da por hecho que estos
tratamientos son exclusivamente para
parejas lo que significa que en Corea en
la práctica es imposible que una mujer
por sí sola puede para ellos y no sólo
eso aparte de lo que ya dice de por sí
la ley la Iglesia surcoreana También se
opone fervientemente a estas técnicas
para mujeres solteras y hablamos de un
país en el que la relación entre los
políticos y las congregaciones
religiosas suele ser muy pero que muy
estrecha
y queridos amigos amigas todo esto cobra
todavía más importancia si tenemos en
cuenta otro de los problemas a los que
las mujeres jóvenes surcoreanas hoy no
se quieren enfrentar y es básicamente a
los roles tradicionales que Todavía
existen en la sociedad surcoreana
respecto a la maternidad y el matrimonio
digamos que las ambiciones profesionales
y personales de las mujeres jóvenes en
este país han cambiado mucho más rápido
de lo que lo ha hecho la percepción de
su rol en la sociedad por ejemplo es muy
pero que muy frecuente que en Corea los
hombres le dejen a las mujeres toda la
carga de criar a sus hijos a pesar de
que estás trabajen en Corea del Sur los
niños son cosas estrictamente de mujeres
y lógicamente eso no es fácil de
compatibilizar con la vida moderna y las
legítimas aspiraciones personales y
profesionales de cientos y cientos de
miles millones de mujeres es algo que os
hemos dicho muchas veces en
visualpolitik las narrativas cuentan y
vaya que si cuentan y a ver no
desconozco no estamos hablando de
telepatriarcado ni de cosas por el
estilo sino de unos roles sociales que
en la inmensa mayor parte de occidente
han sido ya superados pero que no ha
ocurrido lo mismo en Corea del Sur ni en
Asia en general y luego Sí por supuesto
también está el tema de los salarios el
deseo de tener carreras profesionales y
las viviendas
extremadamente caras algo de lo que por
cierto ya os hemos hablado en anteriores
vídeos
Pues bien El caso es que la suma de
todos estos motivos ha hecho que cada
vez más mujeres jóvenes tengan la
sensación de que tanto el matrimonio
como la maternidad son una carga
innecesaria más bien un problema para
ellas al que no tienen ninguna gana de
enfrentarse creéis un dato llamativo de
acuerdo a un estudio realizado en 2020
el 42 y medio por ciento de los
surcoreanos en la treintena no están
casados 13 puntos más que en 2010 los
romances se disparan en Corea del Sur
pero el matrimonio ya no es el objetivo
final de hecho de todos los hogares que
hay en Corea del Sur Ni más ni menos que
cuatro de cada 10 están formados por una
sola persona y en 2022 se registró el
número más bajo de matrimonios desde
1970 con menos de 192.000 en Corea del
Sur las mujeres jóvenes cada vez tienen
menos ganas de casarse y asumir todo lo
que yo conlleva en la cultura y la
sociedad de este país y ya habéis visto
que sin matrimonio tampoco hay niños o
al menos hay muchísimos menos pero
aún hay más
por mucho que estos pueda sorprender
existe Incluso un movimiento femenino
conocido como el de los cuatro noes no a
tener citas no a tener sexo con hombres
no al matrimonio y no a tener hijos la
familia tradicional es cada vez menos
popular entre los jóvenes de este país y
ya habéis visto que tal y como están
montadas las cosas eso tiene
consecuencias Pero llegas a este punto y
ahora que ya sabéis Cuáles son las
principales causas de esta tebacle
demográfica puede que muchos os estéis
haciendo una pregunta qué diablos está
haciendo el gobierno para tratar de
solucionar esta situación acaso puede
hacer algo pues bien Lo cierto es que sí
sí que han hecho y siguen haciendo cosas
pero podríamos decir que en fin parece
como si dirán palos de Ciego a la
desesperada queréis saber cuáles
probablemente la parte más divertida de
toda esta historia pues prestad mucha
atención
matando
[Música]
moscas a cañonazos
os hago una pregunta y si os dijera que
Corea del Sur ha dilapidado
200.000 millones de dólares en los
últimos 16 años en políticas para
fomentar la natalidad y sin embargo no
han conseguido absolutamente nada de
nada 200.000 millones de dólares después
el número de nacimientos está en mínimos
históricos lo que por cierto supone todo
un aviso Navegantes a tantos políticos
que se piensan que este tema de la
natalidad se solucionando de chequera
amigos amigas el estado surcoreano ha de
lapidado unos 12.500 millones de dólares
cada año en políticas de natalidad esto
es más o menos el presupuesto que un
país como España destina a defensa
anualmente y como veis el resultado ha
sido ninguno puede ser que Corea sea el
ejemplo perfecto de como la natalidad no
se fomenta con dinero público pues
Quizás sí quizás estemos ante el ejemplo
más salvaje que ver pero es que lo peor
de todo No es eso lo peor de todo es que
el gobierno sigue optando por esa vía a
pesar de admitir que no funciona 31 de
agosto de 2022 coria triplicará los
cheques bebé Después de batir su propio
récord con la tasa de fertilidad más
baja del mundo para que os hagáis una
idea Que el presidente y un ha anunciado
que triplicaría el cheque bebé que ya
existía Durante los primeros dos años de
vida del recién nacido un incremento que
supondrá pasar de los 300.000 wones que
estableció el presidente montsein a un
millón de wones al cambio algo más de
750 dólares cada mes y no no nos
engañemos el resultado seguramente No
cambia nada
en los países ricos como Corea el tener
o no hijos tiene que ver más con motivos
sociales y culturales no tanto con
problemas económicos si el entorno es
adecuado y las personas se sienten
protegidas y alentadas a tener hijos
tendrán bebés Incluso si se les dice que
no lo hagan los incentivos en dinero por
sí solos no pueden hacer mucho para
impulsar la natalidad son insum profesor
de asistencia social en la universidad
femenina egua Claro que lo cierto Es que
incluso esta medida probablemente tan
inútil como la anterior sea mejor que
otras ocurrencias disparatadas que han
tenido los políticos surcoreanos para
enfrentarse a este problema algunas de
ellas son tan locas que Cualquiera
podría pensar que están desesperados
dando palos de ciego no nos creéis
pensáis que estamos exagerando pues
tomad nota
[Música]
una docena de legisladores presentaron
la propuesta de inundar el país de
niñeras extranjeras con sueldos por
debajo del salario mínimo de hecho la
propuesta incluía que no se aplicase el
salario mínimo a las niñeras extranjeras
Esto es algo que ya se ha hecho en
países como Singapur bajo la excusa de
que las condiciones siguen siendo mucho
mejores que en sus países de origen pero
sea como sea es algo que en Corea
levantó muchísimas críticas
[Música]
luego también se ha propuesto eximir del
servicio militar obligatorio a los
hombres que tengan tres o más hijos
antes de los 30 años El problema es que
los hombres son los únicos que están
obligados a hacer el servicio militar Y
qué quieres que os diga por muchos
hombres que estén dispuestos a liberarse
de la molesta mil y de esta manera si no
hay mujeres dispuestas a tener hijos y
eso no sirve de nada pero esperad un
momento porque ahora os garantizo que
viene lo bueno de verdad
[Música]
las dos cosas que vamos a contar ahora
se hicieron realidad no se trata de
ninguna broma fijaos 31 de diciembre de
2016 Corea del Sur retira una web que
mapea a las mujeres en edad reproductiva
Corea del Sur ha cerrado un sitio web
del gobierno que muestra el número de
mujeres de entre 15 y 49 años en edad
fértil por distritos y regiones después
de una protesta pública los usuarios
podían consultar Cuántas mujeres de esas
edades residían en su barrio Durante los
últimos 10 años Es como una especie de
caravana del amor pero en versión online
instada por el gobierno nos parece
brillante en fin Pues eso se llama la
atención todavía no habéis visto nada en
Corea hay gobiernos locales que han
estado subvencionando la compra de
esposas extranjeras Sí sí tal y como lo
escucháis 19 de febrero de 2019
subsidios locales fomentan en Corea del
Sur la compra de novias extranjeras las
novias de Uzbekistán son las más caras
más de 35 gobiernos municipales han
implementado subsidios matrimoniales a
los hombres locales que se casan con
novias extranjeras eras hablamos de toda
una industria que ya tiene unos cuantos
años en Corea
de hecho Incluso en el mismo seúl hay
establecimientos negocios donde puedes
ir elegir una mujer en un catálogo y
luego se desembolsar una cantidad de
dinero estas empresas gestionan que
estas mujeres se vengan desde su país
para casarse contigo lógicamente no de
forma obligada Pero en fin sea como sea
es de locos Corea del Sur es junto con
Taiwán el país asiático en el que más se
lleva a cabo esta práctica para algunos
Este es un claro ejemplo de tráfico de
personas pero para otros no es más que
una intermediación como cualquier otra
de hecho este tipo de actividad tiene
nombre y apellido se les llama Brokers
matrimoniales y ojo que hay casi 400 en
todo el país y no sé qué quieres que os
diga consideraciones Morales aparte
quizás el que haya administraciones
públicas subvencionando estas
operaciones con casi hasta 10.000
dólares sí que cruza todos los límites Y
sí eso es exactamente lo que algunos
municipios hacen el resultado en este
gráfico lo podéis ver perfectamente
sea como sea ya lo habéis visto Corea
del Sur tiene un problema de natalidad
tan grave que puede poner al propio país
en el camino de su propia extinción un
problema que lejos de mejorar no hace
más que ir a peor cada vez más mujeres
rechazan la maternidad y el matrimonio y
eso en una sociedad y bajo unas
instituciones que todavía son incapaces
de aceptar otros tipos de maternidad o
roles adaptar las políticas públicas es
un problema grave pero hasta aquí el
turno es para ti quieres ir Corea del
Sur podría revertir su gran problema
demográfico con otro tipo de políticas
públicas ha fracasado y el viejo modelo
de creer que para tener hijos solo hace
falta regalar más y más dinero qué
opináis las propuestas y las políticas
que están impulsando en Corea para
lograr que nazcan más niños déjanos tu
opinión aquí abajo y en los comentarios
y recuerda si te ha gustado este vídeo
No olvides darle al botón de like
suscribirte a nuestro canal y darle a la
campanita Para no perderte ninguna
novedad que esté por llegar Ah y muy
importante si queréis ayudarnos a seguir
creciendo y mejorando puede sumarte a
nuestra comunidad en patreon con la que
recibirás contenidos exclusivos os
dejamos el link en la descripción una
vez más Muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]